so today I'm going to be talking to you
guys it's a little different than
survival analysis which I did in the
workshop it's neuroimaging analysis
completely done in R alright so to give
a little bit of background about myself
I am a professor at Whale Cornell in the
division of biostatistics I've been a
professor for two whole weeks so I have
no clue what I'm going but thank you
thank you but hopefully I'll get the
hang of it and I'll have that down a
little better soon but before I went to
academia I actually worked as an
industry data scientist so I worked at a
small startup company called Cove era
health and then I worked over at
Flatiron Health I think they're one of
the sponsors here so I was working on
the quantitative science team there so I
have a little bit of experience in
industry and some experience in the
academic realm all right but I'm going
to talk to you guys today about is
working with structural magnetic
resonance imaging completely in our so
how many people know what structural
magnetic resonance imaging is not very
many people so I'm very thankful that I
have my next couple of slides that will
introduce you to this data so structural
MRI of the brain is used in clinical
practice to diagnose disease and monitor
disease progression so I have three
examples of structural MRI up right now
so these are axial slices of the brain
so they've been sliced this way the
front of the brain is the top of the
image and the back of the brain is the
bottom of the image on the far left I
have a patient who has brain cancer so
you can see the tumor in their brain in
the center this is a patient who has
multiple sclerosis their brain has
lesions these like hyper intense areas
on the brain and on the far right this
is a person who suffered from a stroke
which you can see the area with the
stroke and so these structural images
are what's used in clinical practice to
kind of follow patients and diagnose
disease they're just high-resolution
images of the brain I'm not dealing with
functional MRI functional MRI is MRI
taken over time so you have many many
different images taken quickly with like
less spatial resolution
these have high spatial resolution and
so all of us here are you know
interested in numbers interested in data
so where does the data from these images
come from
so I've blown up a little box on the
image which you can see right here I've
shown where the data is so each one of
the voxels or pixels in this image
corresponds to a number areas that are
darker in the image have lower numbers
areas that are brighter have higher
numbers and so if I have one single
slice this is again an axial slice I
have about 38,000 voxels on that slice
but the cool thing about brain imaging
data you don't just get one slice of the
brain you get a picture of the entire
brain made up of many many different
slices and so now I have about seven
million voxels so I'm starting to get
what I consider big data I think like
other people have much bigger data but
this is big to me and then when you have
a structural MRI study taken you don't
just give one image of your brain taken
but you will get multiple images of your
brain taken with different contrasts to
kind of highlight different areas of the
brain and so you can kind of I think of
it as looking at the brain with
different lenses so you can kind of see
things with these different contrasts so
this is an example of the fluid
attenuated inversion recovery the
t2-weighted the proton density and the
t1-weighted image which are really
commonly taken when you have a
structural MRI and so now I'm up to
about twenty eight million boxes so I've
got quite a bit of data going on for
just one subject all right so I've been
working on neuroimaging analysis for
about a decade and so I'm gonna say like
back in the day to refer to ten years
ago when I started working on this back
in the day you used to use a bunch of
different neural mijung software's to do
your analysis and I would write this
huge bash script where I would call FSL
it's a program that does neuroimaging
analysis and do one thing then I would
call a different program ants and I
would kind of piece these all together
I had the messiest code that you've ever
seen and so somebody went and they
solved this problem for me so how many
people have used bioconductor before
all right how about neuro conductor one
four oh yeah cuz you came to my tutorial
last week okay I was like oh you say
excellent all right so it's one person
two people have used three three people
have used neuro conductor that was like
three more than I thought
so neuro conductor is like the analogous
of bioconductor but for using
neuroimaging data it's an open source
platform for wrapping testing and
dissemination of imaging software for
neuroimaging basically there's like
large educational component where people
go around giving education about how to
use these packages and it's just like
one central repository for all the art
packages to do imaging analysis and so
here's the website and here's a list of
some of the packages that are on there
and this is the team that developed it
so it's Adi gehrman John Michell II
Brian CAFO and chip Rio and chronic
Schiano so these are the guys the core
guys who developed neuro conductor so
they're the the visionaries behind this
this great thing and so what neuro
conductor allows you to do is to now do
all of your neuro imaging analysis
completely in our and it all starts with
this one command so if you just type
source and this website you're all ready
to go
working in neuro conductor just type
this into our and so I'm going to show
you a little bit of analysis with
neuroimaging data to kind of whet your
appetite for maybe working with this so
nourishing imaging data is saved as
nifty files and nifty files are just
files that have a dot NII or dot ini igz
extension it's the most commonly used
type of file in neuro mijung data
analysis and they are just files that
save those three dimensional arrays of
data that I was talking about when we
work with neuroimaging data and so if
you want to go ahead and do this the the
like most useful package or I think the
coolest package now it's not the coolest
package on neuro conductor I have one on
there that I think cool but it's a
really like this is like the workhorse
and it's or own if T so if you just type
neuro install after you've installed a
neuro conductor you can install any
package you want from neuro conductor so
I'm going to install neuro nifty and
just use it like I normally use a
library and so or ODOT nifty goes a
heads and writes and reads nifty files
and then it also has really great ways
for visualizing this data and so I'm
going to use an example so if you guys
want to go if you get super excited
after this presentation and you want to
go do some neuroimaging analysis I would
lead you to this website right here so
this is the Kirby 21 data set and
basically we have scan rescan data from
subjects so they go in they get one scan
and then they go in and get a second
scan so we can see if there's any
differences from the scanner between
those two different scans and so it's
like a free data source where you can
get started working with this data
immediately and so I'm going to read
this in with the Oro nifty package and
so the function I'm going to use is read
nifty and so I just type read nifty and
the name of my file and so now I have
this image in my R space which is my
neuroimaging data if I look at the
dimension of that it's a hundred and
seventy by 256 by 256 so this is that
three dimensional array but like the
main thing I'm always interested in is
cool pictures so I want to see this data
and kind of visualize what's going on
and auradon nifty has this really nice
function called the orthographic
function and so if I type orthographic
image I get this guy and this I think is
just so cool because it's an axial slice
of the brain a sagittal and a coronal
slice of the brain so we get kind of the
idea of what's going on three
dimensionally and I can actually publish
these so like if I'm doing an analysis
like this picture I think it looks good
enough for a journal do you guys think
so yeah yeah and it just came out of
like one function from our I just typed
orthographic image and I got this and so
yeah so ortho or oft package has a great
way to immediately impress your friends
by visualizing some neuroimaging data
and then once you've read these images
in it
is just data so you can go ahead and
start kind of doing some operations on
it to analyze it so I could just type
summary image and it'll give me a
summary of the intensities within that
image I could plot the data so if I go
ahead and take it out of that three
dimensional array and turn it into a
vector and save it in a data frame so
I'm going to call that image top frame I
can use ggplot to visualize the
intensities in this image so there's
tons of zeros in this image why are
there tons of zeros the background right
the back black round so I went ahead and
tried to get rid of it by like threshold
intensity is over 5,000 only there's
still a little peak because there's not
all of those are a value of zero there's
a little bit of variation in it but now
you can kind of start to see maybe two
distinct if you take away that
background blip two distinct
distributions and those are the
distribution of the white matter and the
gray matter so you can start to
visualize the data we have like nice
pictures of it but we're also kind of
working with the numbers themselves and
visualizing those and so all that from
just one package which is pretty cool
there's also this package that John
Michell II the guy who created neuro
conductor made called
F SLR so I can install F SLR and F SLR
is basically just a set of system
commands so you still need to have this
neuroimaging software called FSL
installed on your machine but you don't
have to mess around with learning all
the syntax for FSL r will call FSL for
you using the F SLR package and perform
all the operations that you want so you
just like I have forgot all of my syntax
for FSL because I am an F SLR user so if
F SLR ever goes away I will be very very
things won't be good for me yeah so what
does F SLR do
so when data comes off of a scanner they
come in different orientations so right
here I have two axial of the oriented
things the flare and the PD and then two
Sajid liore
two images so if I want to talk about a
voxel across all four of these images
it's impossible because it's not in the
same space so I want to move all of
these images to the same space I also
noticed that there is a skull on the
image and I might not be interested in
skull tissue I might only be interested
in doing an analysis on brain tissue so
I might want to remove the skull and so
f SLR allows you to do all of that
completely in R which is like three or
four commands so entirely an R and so
those commands are FSL bias correct FS
I'll bet and flirt and so you could
string those together and do that
analysis and so just to show you like
what's going on under the hood I
mentioned this before but these are all
just system commands so we have the
software FSL that's running all these
things and these are pretty complicated
algorithms so instead of rewriting those
in R we are just going to use system
commands to call FSL through R but you
could just type in the are commands and
it makes it much easier for you
alright so I gave you like a little
rundown of like what we could do in
these cases but if you really want to
dig deep into this and like learn the
background and how to work with these
things we have a book chapter called the
statistical analysis of structural MRI
neuroimaging data which goes through all
of the steps for how to do the
neuroimaging analysis and contains our
code for doing that and then I'm also an
ACO instructor on a Coursera class
called neuro hacking in our that goes
through how to do all of this analysis
completely in our so this is a great way
to get started if you want to start
working on this data and like you know
really dive in and we've got lots of
access to like open source data sets so
you can get started get started on some
projects and and those types of things
ok so now I want to talk about one of
the packages that I have that's hosted
on neuro conductor
so we were talking about structural MRI
and in the beginning I was talking about
patients who have multiple sclerosis so
patients who have multiple sclerosis
have lesions in their brain and these
lesions are what are used in clinical
trials as like a primary outcome so if
you want to test the difference between
two different treatments will often look
at the volume of lesions or the volume
of lesion change in those patients to
determine what treatment is doing better
than another treatment and so I've
highlighted here where those lesions are
in the brain in a typical clinical trial
setting a radiologist actually sits down
and goes through and highlights where
every single one of those lesions is and
as we were saying these these brain
images have like 180 slices so they've
got to go through 180 slices and
manually delineate how many lesions are
on there and so how long do you think
that takes to do you think it takes
longer than it does yeah I was whenever
I say something like how much do you
think it cost did somebody would be like
$200 I'll be like oh it's only 50 but I
thought it was really expensive yeah no
but for this so two days great guess it
takes an hour
so it takes a radiologist or fast and
good at good at doing this and they have
to do it a lot but it takes a whole hour
and I don't know how much I've always
tried to do this for like this
particular talk like look up how much a
radiologist makes per hour but I've
never I don't think they get paid hourly
and I haven't been able to like get a
calculation so I wanted to get like some
monetary amount to do that but I don't
know when you've got a study and you've
got a couple hundred patients in that
study that's a couple hundred hours of
radiologists work and that that's a long
time
and so that kind of makes a call for
having automated algorithms that can
just do this that can identify those
areas in the brain that have lesions in
them and so that's a project that I
worked on during my PhD thesis the
software is called oasis and so it's
housed as in our package on neuro
conductor so you can just do neuro
install oasis library oasis and right
here I've used orthographic again this
is a patient who has multiple sclerosis
and you'll notice there is a lesion in
the brain right by the ventricle I'll
highlight it with Oasis in just a second
but this is the output for my algorithm
so it actually creates these binary maps
of where lesions are in the brain and so
that's one of the examples of some of
the things that are hosted on neuro
conductor there's other things for like
other diseases like stroke segmentation
like brain cancer segmentation and and
those types of things but I would really
encourage everybody to kind of check
this data out and check out neuro
conductor and see what types of things
are on there alright thank you so much
you